This is Hidden Brain from NPR. I'm Shankar Vedanta. In May 2007, an artist living in Chicago moved into a new place. It was a small room with white walls. The interior design was minimalist. There was a bed, a desk, a computer, a lamp, and a paintball gun. a shooter, a lamp, and a paintball gun.
这里是NPR的《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。2007年5月，一位住在芝加哥的艺术家搬进了一个新住处。那是一个有着白色墙壁的小房间，室内设计走极简主义风格。房间里有一张床、一张书桌、一台电脑、一盏灯，还有一把彩弹枪。
A fix to the gun was a webcam. It live streamed the room to the internet. Anyone could look in, and anyone could take control of the gun, aim, and fire. At all hours of the day and night, the paintball gun would spring to life and begin shooting yellow pellets into the room. Some hit the walls or the furniture. Some hit the artist.
枪上安装了一个网络摄像头，将房间的画面实时直播到互联网上。任何人都可以观看，也可以控制这把枪进行瞄准和射击。无论白天还是黑夜，这把彩弹枪随时都会启动，开始向房间里发射黄色弹丸。有些打在了墙上或家具上，有些则打在了艺术家身上。
I was shot at 70,000 times and I received 80 million hits on the internet from 128 countries. Waffa Bilal spent one whole month in the room, targeted tens of thousands of times by random strangers around the world. Why would he choose to do this? Wafa was born and raised in Iraq. He came to the US in the early 90s. I live this duality of living in two places. One is a comfort zone of United States and the other one is the conflict zone in Iraq where my family, friends, live. In 2004, Wafa says one of his brothers was killed in an airstrike. One of my brother, Haji, was killed in air to ground missile.
“我被击中了7万次，在互联网上获得了8000万次点击，来自128个国家。”瓦法·比拉尔（Waffa Bilal）在那个房间里整整待了一个月，被世界各地随机的陌生人瞄准了数万次。他为什么要选择这样做？瓦法在伊拉克出生长大，90年代初来到美国。“我过着这种身处两地的双重生活。一边是美国的舒适区，另一边是伊拉克的冲突区，我的家人和朋友都住在那里。”2004年，瓦法说他的一个兄弟在空袭中丧生。“我的一个兄弟，哈吉，死于空对地导弹。”
And I didn't know what to do. Wafa is a performance artist, and he wanted to engage others in the conversation that was running through his mind. Three years after his brother's death, he got an idea. In January of 2007, I was watching TV and I was watching an interview with an American soldier sitting in the United States, the soldier directed drones to fire missiles thousands of miles away in the Iraqi desert. miles away in the Iraqi desert. I was shocked how the soldier completely disconnected physically and emotionally from what happened on the ground of Iraq. At the time, Wafa was living in Chicago.
“我不知道该怎么办。”瓦法是一位行为艺术家，他想让其他人参与到他脑海中正在进行的对话中。在他兄弟去世三年后，他想到了一个主意。2007年1月，“我当时在看电视，看到了一段对一名美国士兵的采访，他坐在美国境内，指挥无人机在数千英里外的伊拉克沙漠中发射导弹。我感到震惊的是，这名士兵在身体和情感上与伊拉克地面上发生的事情完全脱节。”当时，瓦法住在芝加哥。
He came up with a proposal and presented it to a gallery. I said, I want to lock myself in the gallery space for 30 days and I get a built a robot connected to the internet and the robot shoots a pinball and viewers online could direct that gun and shoot it. And there you go. That's another shot. Let's see. This one from... It says from Milwaukee. You can see it. The idea was to turn ordinary people into drone operators who could target someone far away.
他提出了一个方案并提交给了一家画廊。“我说，我想把自己锁在画廊空间里30天，我造了一个连接到互联网的机器人，机器人会发射彩弹，在线观众可以指挥那把枪进行射击。就这样。又是一枪。让我们看看。这一枪来自……说是来自密尔沃基。你可以看到它。”这个想法是将普通人变成无人机操作员，让他们可以瞄准远方的人。
Except, in this case, people would not be following orders. They would have a choice about whether to shoot and you could see the human being on the other end. Wafa's suffering would be visible. When you are in this little room, you see the sheer destruction but if you are online, it becomes like a video game and that another thing that I wanted to connect with people, that there is real consequences to these actions. It's a disease. My body is just getting weak by the day. I thought I felt better. As the days went by, Wafas started to feel weak by the day. I thought I felt better. As the days went by, Wafa started to feel crushed
不同的是，在这种情况下，人们不会是在执行命令。他们可以选择是否开枪，而且你可以看到另一端是一个活生生的人。瓦法的痛苦将是可见的。“当你在这个小房间里时，你看到了纯粹的破坏，但如果你是在网上，它就变得像个电子游戏，这也是我想与人们建立联系的另一点，即这些行为是有真实后果的。”“这是一种折磨。我的身体一天天虚弱下去。我以为我感觉好些了。”随着日子一天天过去，瓦法开始感到崩溃。
by the experience. It's late at night. I feel extremely tired. But I'm afraid she goes to bed. In some ways, Wafa was attempting to do what civil disobedience movements around the world have done. He was deliberately putting himself in harm's way in order to draw attention to a problem and affect change.
“因为这次经历。现在是深夜。我感到非常疲惫。但我很害怕。”她上床睡觉了。在某种程度上，瓦法试图做世界各地的公民不服从运动所做的事情。他故意让自己处于危险之中，以引起人们对某个问题的关注并促成改变。
I have United States, I have Denmark, I have Ireland, I have the UK, I have United States, I have Denmark, I have Ireland, I have the UK, I have France again, Canada, so it's not one place. It is almost a global shooting and I don't know. Somebody said imagine the entire They live like this. Why did strangers who knew nothing about Wafa take it upon themselves to hurt him? Do technology in modern life and the anonymity they offer make us less caring as human beings? On today's show, Building Empathy in a Connected and Confrontational World. Support for Hidden Brain and the following message come from American Express. You want to build your business.
“我有来自美国、丹麦、爱尔兰、英国、法国、加拿大的参与者，所以它不是来自一个地方。这几乎是一场全球性的射击，我不知道。有人说想象一下整个世界。他们就这样生活。”为什么那些对瓦法一无所知的陌生人会主动去伤害他？现代生活中的技术及其提供的匿名性是否让我们作为人类变得不再那么有同情心了？在今天的节目中，我们将探讨在互联且充满对抗的世界中建立同理心。《Hidden Brain》及以下信息由美国运通（American Express）提供支持。你想发展你的业务。
They can help build your business with financing solutions for eligible business customers. The powerful backing of American Express don't do business without it. Terms apply. Visit AmericanExpress.com slash business. Support also comes from Microsoft. Snow Leopards are very difficult to find. This week on Hidden Brain, think deeply. We kick off our annual Summer Series, YouTube.au. Authenticity is contagious.
他们可以通过为符合条件的商业客户提供融资解决方案来帮助你发展业务。美国运通的强大支持，没有它就不要做生意。条款适用。请访问AmericanExpress.com/business。支持也来自微软。雪豹非常难找。本周在《Hidden Brain》节目中，深入思考。我们开启年度夏季系列节目，YouTube.au。真实性是会传染的。
I have been dragged into this all the way kicking and screaming. Ideas and advice about how you can respond to life's chaos. You can do it just check to my inbox. Just check, just check, just check to my phone real quick. With wisdom. We begin the series with an exploration of the power and the cost of empathy. By putting ourselves into the story of people who on the surface
“我被一路拖进这件事里，又踢又叫。”关于如何应对生活混乱的想法和建议。“你可以做到，只要检查我的收件箱。只要检查，只要检查，只要检查我的手机。”带着智慧。我们以探索同理心的力量和代价开启这个系列。通过将我们自己置于那些表面上
appear different from us, we can recognize our common humanity with them and that can trigger empathy in a really natural way. Jameel Zaki is a psychologist at Stanford University. He's the author of the book, The War for Kindness, Building Empathy in a Fractured World. J Jamil, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thanks for having me. You have a very powerful story about how you came to be interested in the subject of empathy. Tell me about your parents, where they are from, how they met, what they went through,
看起来与我们不同的人的故事中，我们可以认识到我们与他们共同的人性，这可以以一种非常自然的方式触发同理心。贾米尔·扎基（Jameel Zaki）是斯坦福大学的心理学家。他是《善良之战：在破碎的世界中建立同理心》（The War for Kindness, Building Empathy in a Fractured World）一书的作者。贾米尔，欢迎来到《Hidden Brain》。谢谢你邀请我。你有一个非常感人的故事，关于你是如何对同理心这个主题产生兴趣的。告诉我关于你父母的事，他们来自哪里，他们是如何相遇的，他们经历了什么，
and what you learned from the experience. So it turns out that in the early 1970s, Washington State University in Pullman had a program where they granted full scholarships for graduate studies to students from the world's poorest nations. My mother received the scholarship from Peru, and my father did not receive the scholarship, but nonetheless came to Washington State from Pakistan. So they traveled from Lima and Lahore, these two massive cities to the sleepy town of Pullman, where they fell in love.
以及你从这段经历中学到了什么。事实证明，在20世纪70年代初，位于普尔曼的华盛顿州立大学有一个项目，为来自世界上最贫穷国家的学生提供研究生学习的全额奖学金。我母亲获得了来自秘鲁的奖学金，而我父亲虽然没有获得奖学金，但还是从巴基斯坦来到了华盛顿州。所以他们从利马和拉合尔这两个巨大的城市来到了普尔曼这个安静的小镇，在那里他们坠入了爱河。
When I think about my parents, I think the biggest thing that they had in common was their sense of foreignness in the US. They sort of took comfort in each other in a place that neither of them understood. But as they grew more comfortable with the U.S. and were acclimated to it, they grew less comfortable with each other. And they divorced. They started splitting up when I was eight, but didn't finish until I was 12, and there's
当我想到我的父母时，我认为他们最大的共同点是他们在美利坚合众国的陌生感。在一个他们都不了解的地方，他们从彼此身上寻求安慰。但随着他们对美国越来越适应，他们对彼此却越来越不适应。于是他们离婚了。他们在我八岁时开始分居，直到我12岁才正式离婚，那是一段
was a long and acrimonious split, and I am their only child. And so a lot of my childhood was spent kind of bouncing around between their houses and it really felt like I was bouncing between parallel universes because their priorities and values and fears are really as far apart as their hometowns. So I would often feel confused, you know, as a small child, I would try to, when I was with my mom, figure out the rules that governed her heart and mind and make them true for myself. But then when I would go to my dad's house,
漫长而痛苦的分裂，而我是他们唯一的孩子。所以我童年的大部分时间都在他们两家之间来回奔波，感觉就像是在平行宇宙之间穿梭，因为他们的优先事项、价值观和恐惧真的和他们的家乡一样遥远。所以我经常感到困惑，你知道，作为一个小孩，当我和妈妈在一起时，我会试图弄清楚支配她内心和思想的规则，并让它们对我自己也适用。但当我回到爸爸家时，
those same rules would stop working. And it was just very confusing and it felt, I think, to all three of us, like, I would really have to choose one of my parents and give up on really knowing the other. But I knew that I had to try for all of our sake. So I did, and I kind of kept working at it, and eventually got better and learned to tune myself to my parents' different frequencies. And that kind of saved me as a kid.
同样的规则就不管用了。这非常令人困惑，我想对我们三个人来说，感觉就像我必须在父母之间做出选择，放弃真正了解另一方。但我知道为了我们所有人，我必须尝试。所以我做到了，我一直在努力，最终变得更好，学会了调整自己以适应父母不同的频率。这在某种程度上拯救了童年的我。
I think empathy saved me. Not because it's easy, it was work. I was thinking of my parents divorced as an empathy gym for me that forced me to work out my ability to care about and understand other people. And you, as you've said, described this as an empathy gem, were there times when you failed to show the empathy? I mean, I must imagine that as a small child, it must have been very difficult in many ways to comprehend what was happening and why these two adults were fighting over you and each was demanding that you see things from their point of view.
我认为同理心拯救了我。不是因为它容易，而是因为这是一种工作。我把父母的离婚看作是我的“同理心健身房”，它强迫我锻炼自己关心和理解他人的能力。正如你所说，你将其描述为“同理心健身房”，有没有你未能表现出同理心的时候？我的意思是，我必须想象作为一个小孩，在很多方面理解正在发生的事情，以及为什么这两个成年人为了你而争吵，并且每个人都要求你从他们的角度看问题，一定是非常困难的。
Oh, absolutely. I mean, one of the big realizations for me as a kid was realizing that both of them were in pain. I think as a child, it's very easy to focus on your own perspective and what you're going through. And to blame others, especially adults, I think when I realized that my parents were both struggling just like I was, it actually made me feel kinship towards them and made it easier to understand that I could connect with both of them. In fact, because what we were going through wasn't that different. Talk a little bit about the benefits of empathy. There's been a lot of work that looks at what happens when people receive empathy from their partners, for example, or from their doctors. Oh, yeah.
哦，当然。我的意思是，作为一个孩子，我最大的感悟之一就是意识到他们两个都在痛苦中。我认为作为一个孩子，很容易专注于自己的视角和你正在经历的事情。并责怪他人，尤其是成年人。我想当我意识到我的父母和我一样都在挣扎时，这实际上让我对他们产生了亲近感，并让我更容易理解我可以与他们双方建立联系。事实上，因为我们正在经历的事情并没有什么不同。谈谈同理心的好处吧。有很多研究观察了人们从伴侣或医生那里获得同理心时会发生什么。哦，是的。
I mean, in many cases, empathy benefits all parties involved. So for instance, patients of empathic doctors are more satisfied with their care, but are also more likely to follow doctors' recommendations, which is important for things like preventative care, and spouses of empathic partners are happier in their marriages. But one thing that I think people don't realize as much is that people who experience empathy for others also benefit. It's not just receiving it, but giving it helps us too. So people who are relatively high in empathy, for instance, are less likely to become depressed.
我的意思是，在许多情况下，同理心对所有相关方都有利。例如，得到有同理心的医生照顾的患者对他们的护理更满意，也更有可能遵循医生的建议，这对于预防性护理等事情很重要；而拥有有同理心的伴侣的配偶在婚姻中也更幸福。但有一点我认为人们没有意识到的是，那些对他人产生同理心的人也会受益。不仅仅是接受它，给予它也能帮助我们。例如，同理心相对较高的人患抑郁症的可能性更小。
Feeling empathy for others reduces our stress and adolescence who are able to pick out other people's emotions accurately are better adjusted during middle school. Now parents everywhere recognize the value of empathy. We have courses and classes that try and teach children empathy. I came by this clip on Sesame Street featuring the actor Mark Ruffalo and the character Murray. Take a listen to the clip. Murray.
对他人产生同理心可以减轻我们的压力，而那些能够准确识别他人情绪的青少年在中学期间适应得更好。现在各地的父母都认识到了同理心的价值。我们有课程和班级试图教孩子们同理心。我看到了《芝麻街》的这个片段，由演员马克·鲁法洛（Mark Ruffalo）和角色默里（Murray）出演。听听这个片段。默里。
What? Did I tell you about that time when I lost my favorite teddy bear? Oh no. It was. This is very sad. Did you love that teddy bear? I love that teddy bear. Oh, I can imagine. I can imagine. Oh no. It was... This is very sad. Did you love that candy?
什么？我有没有告诉过你我弄丢我最喜欢的泰迪熊的那次？哦，不。那是。这非常令人难过。你爱那个泰迪熊吗？我爱那个泰迪熊。哦，我可以想象。我可以想象。哦，不。那是……这非常令人难过。你爱那个糖果吗？
I love that teddy bear. I can imagine exactly how you feel. It really does feel like it makes you want to cry like this. It was sad. It was so sad. But you know what? What? You know what empathy is!
我爱那个泰迪熊。我可以想象你现在的感受。这真的让人想哭，就像这样。那很令人难过。太令人难过了。但你知道吗？什么？你知道什么是同理心！
I do! That was empathy! What? You could understand how I was feeling, exactly how I was feeling and understood it. That's empathy! I can't now! Jamil, you've used a similar kind of scenario to explain empathy.
我知道！那就是同理心！什么？你能理解我的感受，确切地知道我的感受并理解它。那就是同理心！我现在不能了！贾米尔，你用过类似的场景来解释同理心。
Someone's talking with a friend, the friend gets a phone call, walk me through the rest of that scenario and the three components that you've identified that make up empathy. Someone's talking with a friend, the friend gets a phone call, walk me through the rest of that scenario and the three components that you've identified that make up empathy. Yeah, so again, imagine that you're sitting with a friend having lunch and they receive a phone call and whatever the person on the other side of the line says makes them visibly upset. You don't know what's wrong, but your friend starts to cry and it's obvious that something is wrong. Well, as you see this, a bunch of things might happen inside you. First, you might become upset yourself, sort of vicariously catching their feeling.
有人在和朋友聊天，朋友接到了一个电话，带我走过那个场景的其余部分，以及你确定的构成同理心的三个组成部分。有人在和朋友聊天，朋友接到了一个电话，带我走过那个场景的其余部分，以及你确定的构成同理心的三个组成部分。是的，所以再次想象你正和朋友坐在一起吃午饭，他们接到了一个电话，电话那头的人说的任何话都让他们明显感到不安。你不知道出了什么问题，但你的朋友开始哭泣，很明显出了什么问题。好吧，当你看到这一幕时，你的内心可能会发生很多事情。首先，你自己可能会感到不安，这是一种替代性的感受。
That's what psychologists often call emotional empathy. You might also try to figure out what's wrong, what they're feeling, and why. That's what we call cognitive empathy. And if you're a good friend at least, you probably will feel concerned for what they're going through and a desire for their well-being to improve. That's what psychologists call empathic concern or compassion. And even though these pieces of empathy sometimes go together, they also split apart in interesting ways. So for instance, different brain systems support emotional and cognitive empathy and empathic concern. And different groups of people struggle with different flavors of empathy, people with
这就是心理学家常说的“情感同理心”。你可能还会试图弄清楚出了什么问题，他们的感受是什么，以及为什么。这就是我们所说的“认知同理心”。如果你至少是一个好朋友，你可能会为他们正在经历的事情感到担忧，并希望他们的状况能有所改善。这就是心理学家所说的“同理心关怀”或“同情心”。尽管这些同理心的片段有时会结合在一起，但它们也会以有趣的方式分离开来。例如，不同的大脑系统支持情感同理心、认知同理心和同理心关怀。不同的人群在不同类型的同理心上会遇到困难，例如，患有
autism spectrum disorders, for instance, struggle sometimes to understand others, their cognitive empathy, but don't struggle as much to share other people's emotions or care about what other people feel. Individuals with psychopathy have the opposite profile. They're often perfectly able to understand what other people feel, but they don't share those emotions. That's fascinating. It's almost like these are different muscle groups and you need all the muscle groups to be functioning to in some ways
自闭症谱系障碍的人有时难以理解他人，即他们的认知同理心，但在分享他人的情绪或关心他人的感受方面并没有那么大的困难。患有精神病态的人则有相反的特征。他们通常完全能够理解他人的感受，但他们不会分享这些情绪。这太迷人了。这几乎就像这些是不同的肌肉群，你需要所有的肌肉群都能正常运作，才能在某种程度上
actualize your full capacity for empathy. I Love that analogy. Yeah, that's a perfect way of putting it So at the same time that parents and books and motivational speakers and fate traditions cite the value of empathy There is also some evidence that empathy might be There is also some evidence that empathy might be changing over time and not necessarily in a good way. U-Site research that compares the average level of empathy in 2009 to the average in 1979. Yeah, so this is work by Sarah Conrath and her colleagues using the most sort of famous and well-known scale to measure empathy, which is just a questionnaire.
实现你全部的同理心能力。我喜欢这个类比。是的，这是一种完美的表达方式。所以，在父母、书籍、励志演说家和信仰传统引用同理心价值的同时，也有一些证据表明同理心可能正在随着时间的推移而改变，而且不一定是朝着好的方向。你引用了比较2009年和1979年平均同理心水平的研究。是的，这是莎拉·康拉斯（Sarah Konrath）和她的同事使用最著名和最广为人知的同理心测量量表进行的研究，这只是一个问卷调查。
In this questionnaire, people see a number of statements and they're asked how much they agree with that statement, from one, not at all, to five, extremely. So a sample statement might be, I often have tender, concerned feelings for people less fortunate than myself, or I try to look at everyone's side of a disagreement before I make a decision. So a series of questions like that give you a sort of empathy score, again from one to five. People have taken this questionnaire over several decades, and if you compare their scores over time, they've been dwindling or eroding. And what's more troubling is that a lot of this decline happened pretty recently,
在这个问卷中，人们会看到许多陈述，并被要求说明他们对该陈述的同意程度，从1（完全不同意）到5（非常同意）。例如，一个样本陈述可能是：“我经常对那些不如我幸运的人产生温柔、关心的感觉”，或者“在做出决定之前，我尽量从分歧的各个方面来看待问题”。所以一系列这样的问题会给你一个同理心分数，同样是从1到5。人们在过去几十年里一直在做这个问卷，如果你比较他们随时间的分数，它们一直在减少或侵蚀。更令人不安的是，这种下降很大程度上发生在最近，
sort of since the turn of the 21st century. Let's talk about some of the reasons this might be happening. You offer various theories in the book. Among people 18 to 34, for example, ten times as many people live alone today as did in 1950. You say that more than half of all residents in Paris and Stockholm live alone in some parts of Manhattan and Los Angeles that number tops 90% is there a link between going solo and the amount of empathy we feel for others?
也就是21世纪之交以来。让我们谈谈这可能发生的一些原因。你在书中提供了各种理论。例如，在18到34岁的人群中，今天独自生活的人数是1950年的十倍。你说巴黎和斯德哥尔摩的所有居民中有一半以上独自生活，在曼哈顿和洛杉矶的部分地区，这个数字超过了90%。独自生活与我们对他人的同理心之间是否存在联系？
It's hard to say you know, and I do want to be clear that in looking at any demographic trends over time and trying to link them to Empathy decline. We're necessarily speculating? There's no way to run an experiment where you have history occur multiple times and fiddle with different pieces of it to see what causes a decline in empathy, but certainly, you know, you can point to big shifts in the way that people live,
很难说，你知道，我确实想明确一点，在观察任何随时间推移的人口统计趋势并试图将它们与同理心下降联系起来时，我们必然是在推测。没有办法进行一个实验，让历史发生多次，并摆弄其中的不同部分来看看是什么导致了同理心的下降，但当然，你知道，你可以指出人们生活方式的巨大转变，
and one of them is that we're becoming more urban and more solitary. And when we interact with people, it's often in more transactional ways. live and one of them is that we're becoming more urban and more solitary. And when we interact with people, it's often in more transactional ways, right? Some of the regular rituals that used to bring us into contact with other people often are giving way to more solitary pursuits. So there's some evidence, for instance, that anonymous interactions do not favor empathy. So I don't know, there's not data specifically on solitary living, but to the extent that living in,
其中之一就是我们变得越来越城市化和孤独。当我们与人互动时，往往是以更交易的方式。其中之一就是我们变得越来越城市化和孤独。当我们与人互动时，往往是以更交易的方式，对吧？过去常让我们与他人接触的一些常规仪式往往正在让位于更孤独的追求。所以有一些证据表明，例如，匿名互动不利于同理心。所以我不知道，没有关于独自生活的具体数据，但就生活在
you know, a giant city, but by yourself, where most of the people who you see are total strangers, there's some evidence that suggests that perhaps that might have an effect on our empathy. And of course, one of the other places where anonymity rules is the internet. And when you look at some of the changes that have unfolded and the timetable of those changes, they do coincide at least, correlationally, with the rise of internet technologies. And I'm wondering, is there reason to imagine that there's a connection between these two things, that the connections we have with one another online and on Twitter or social media, where we often don't know whom we are communicating with or who's listening or who's not listening?
一个巨大的城市里，但却是独自一人，你看到的大多数人都是完全的陌生人而言，有一些证据表明这可能对我们的同理心有影响。当然，匿名规则适用的另一个地方是互联网。当你观察已经发生的一些变化以及这些变化的时间表时，它们至少在相关性上与互联网技术的兴起是一致的。我想知道，是否有理由想象这两者之间存在联系，即我们在网上、Twitter或社交媒体上与他人的联系，在那里我们通常不知道我们在与谁交流，或者谁在听，谁不在听？
Could this in some ways be behind this decline in empathy? It certainly is possible. I think that the internet and social media, I don't think of them as inherently anti-social. In a way, you can think of the internet as humanity's greatest empathic opportunity ever. We have the chance to connect with people around the world at any time on their own terms and respond with compassion. I mean, I think if you go back and read, wired, you know, 10 or 15 years ago, people were waxing poetic about the way that the Internet could bring us all together into a global community. I think in some obvious ways that hasn't always occurred, and I think
这在某种程度上可能是同理心下降的原因吗？这当然是有可能的。我认为互联网和社交媒体，我不认为它们本质上是反社会的。在某种程度上，你可以把互联网看作是人类有史以来最大的同理心机会。我们有机会在任何时候按照他们自己的条件与世界各地的人联系，并以同情心回应。我的意思是，如果你回去读读10或15年前的《连线》杂志，人们当时还在诗意地谈论互联网如何能将我们所有人聚集到一个全球社区中。我认为在某些显而易见的方式上，这种情况并不总是发生，而且我认为
that has to do in part with some of the ways that we tend to use the Internet that might not be empathy positive. So for instance, oftentimes online, we don't have a chance to see each other's faces and voices in sort of real-time interactions, the kind of richness that we have when we hang out offline. Instead, we see avatars and strings of text, and those might not be great triggers for empathy. There's a great study by Juliana Schroder and her colleagues where they had people describe their political opinions sort of in an audio recording. They then had a separate group of people
这在一定程度上与我们使用互联网的一些方式有关，这些方式可能对同理心没有积极作用。例如，在网上，我们往往没有机会在实时互动中看到彼此的面孔和声音，那种我们在离线相处时拥有的丰富性。相反，我们看到的是头像和一串串文字，这些可能不是同理心的良好触发因素。朱莉安娜·施罗德（Juliana Schroder）和她的同事做了一项很棒的研究，他们让人们以音频记录的方式描述他们的政治观点。然后他们让另一组人
listen to those audio recordings or read a transcript of them. And what they found was that people were more likely to dehumanize the person whose opinion was they were reading about if they were only reading it. Whereas if they were hearing the person's voice, they were less likely to dehumanize that individual. So it's almost as though we're leaving behind when we go online some of the cues that allow us to detect each other's real humanity.
听这些音频记录或阅读它们的文字记录。他们发现，如果人们只是在阅读，他们更有可能将他们正在阅读其观点的人非人化。而如果他们听到那个人的声音，他们就不太可能将那个人非人化。所以这几乎就像我们在上网时丢掉了一些让我们能够察觉彼此真实人性的线索。
And there's a deep irony there isn't that, Jimmy? I mean, when we live in these big cities, we're living cheek by jowl with lots of other people, but in some ways we're not connecting with them, and the same goes with the internet when we have the capacity to connect with large numbers of other people, but we're connecting in often the superficial way instead of this deeper way. It is ironic, isn't it? I mean, in cities, for instance, we see more people than we ever did in human history,
这其中有一个深刻的讽刺，不是吗，贾米尔？我的意思是，当我们生活在这些大城市时，我们与许多其他人紧密相连，但在某种程度上我们并没有与他们建立联系，互联网也是如此，当我们有能力与大量其他人建立联系时，我们却以一种肤浅的方式而不是这种更深层的方式进行联系。这很讽刺，不是吗？我的意思是，在城市里，例如，我们看到的人比人类历史上任何时候都多，
but we know fewer of them. And it almost is as though our interactions sort of favor a dehumanized perspective on each other. I mean, I know what I'm sort of stuck in traffic or trying to make my way down a crowded block in Manhattan. People become not people, but obstacles for me on my way. And I think that that's sort of the way that it can often feel in modern contexts.
但我们认识的人却更少。这几乎就像我们的互动在某种程度上偏向于一种对他人的非人化视角。我的意思是，我知道当我被困在交通中或试图穿过曼哈顿拥挤的街区时，人们对我来说不再是人，而是我前进道路上的障碍。我认为这在现代语境下往往就是这种感觉。
When we come back, more on the signs of empathy and why being empathetic can sometimes be bad for you. Support for Hidden Brain and the following message come from Rocket Mortgage by Quick and Loans. Imagine how it feels to have an award-winning team of mortgage experts make the home-buying process smoother for you. With a history of industry leading online lending technology, Rocket Mortgage is changing the game.
回来后，我们将更多地讨论同理心的迹象，以及为什么有同理心有时会对你不利。《Hidden Brain》及以下信息由Quicken Loans旗下的Rocket Mortgage提供支持。想象一下，拥有一支屡获殊荣的抵押贷款专家团队让你的购房过程更顺畅，那是什么感觉。凭借行业领先的在线贷款技术历史，Rocket Mortgage正在改变游戏规则。
Visit rocketmortgage.com slash brain. Equal housing lender licensed in all 50 states, nmlsconsumeraccess.org, number 3030. Rocket Mortgage by Quickenloans. Push button, Git Mortgage. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Jameel Zaki is the author of the War for Kindness, building empathy in a fractured world. He conducts research on empathy at Stanford University.
访问rocketmortgage.com/brain。平等住房贷款人，在所有50个州获得许可，nmlsconsumeraccess.org，编号3030。Quicken Loans旗下的Rocket Mortgage。按一下按钮，获得抵押贷款。这里是《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。贾米尔·扎基是《善良之战：在破碎的世界中建立同理心》的作者。他在斯坦福大学进行同理心研究。
Jameel people who have been through terrible suffering can respond in different ways. Some people turn inward to avoid future pain while others turn outward. They show empathy for the suffering of other people. I feel like I've seen research studies that show both these things. Can you talk about these studies and why people might go in one direction or another after the experience trauma? Yeah, I think that we often think of trauma, sort of things like being through a war or being assaulted or suffering a terrible injury as things that, again, as you put it nicely sort of draw us into each other, or even that trauma might perpetuate itself. We often hear about cycles of violence or the idea that hurt people, hurt people.
贾米尔，经历过可怕痛苦的人可以以不同的方式做出反应。有些人转向内心以避免未来的痛苦，而另一些人则转向外部。他们对他人的痛苦表现出同理心。我觉得我看到的研究表明了这两种情况。你能谈谈这些研究，以及为什么人们在经历创伤后可能会朝着一个或另一个方向发展吗？是的，我认为我们经常认为创伤，比如经历战争、被袭击或遭受可怕的伤害，是那些，正如你很好地表达的那样，将我们拉向彼此的事情，甚至创伤可能会自我延续。我们经常听到暴力循环或“受伤的人伤害人”的观点。
And that's certainly true in some cases, but there is a lot of research that's actually much more hopeful on what psychologists call altruism born of suffering. This is the idea that sometimes when we've gone through great pain, that actually sort of opens us up to caring more about other people and their suffering. So there are all sorts of examples of that as well. So for instance, people who have suffered from addiction often change their lives and become addiction counselors. People who have been assaulted often change their lives and become assault counselors, sort of because they resonate with the frequency of other people suffering more acutely.
这在某些情况下当然是真的，但有很多研究实际上对心理学家所说的“源于痛苦的利他主义”更为乐观。这就是说，有时当我们经历过巨大的痛苦时，这实际上会让我们更关心他人和他们的痛苦。所以也有各种各样的例子。例如，遭受成瘾折磨的人经常改变他们的生活并成为成瘾咨询师。遭受袭击的人经常改变他们的生活并成为袭击咨询师，因为他们能更敏锐地与他人痛苦的频率产生共鸣。
Psychologists don't really know that much about sort of what causes people when they experience suffering to go in one direction or another, but one important factor that they have identified is the support that we receive from other people. So if after a trauma an individual is able to find a community of others who support them, well then they're more likely to recover from their own trauma, and they might also be more likely to turn around and provide that support to others. I'm thinking about research that Michael Wall and Nile Bransk and others have done, looking at how when you remind people of past traumas, you remind Americans, for example, of the 9-11 attacks, Americans become more willing to endorse or tolerate harsh interrogation techniques in the fight against
心理学家并不真正了解是什么导致人们在经历痛苦时朝着一个或另一个方向发展，但他们确定的一个重要因素是我们从他人那里得到的支持。所以，如果一个人在创伤后能够找到一个支持他们的社区，那么他们就更有可能从自己的创伤中恢复过来，他们也可能更有可能转过身来为他人提供这种支持。我正在思考迈克尔·沃尔（Michael Wall）和奈尔·布兰斯克（Nile Bransk）等人所做的研究，观察当你提醒人们过去的创伤时，例如提醒美国人9-11袭击，美国人会变得更愿意支持或容忍在反恐斗争中的严厉审讯技术。
terrorism. And in some ways at one level, this seems very intuitive, that you feel like you've been through something bad, and I remind you of the bad thing you've been through and there's a part of you that says I don't want that bad thing to happen again And that increases my willingness to permit Actions or behaviors that might I might otherwise say hang on a second. This is gonna cause harm to other people Yeah, absolutely and I mean, I think that that it cuts both ways, right? I mean, I think that it cuts both ways, right? I mean, I think reminding people of collective trauma, for instance, can make them more weary of outsiders and sort of more, as you say, willing to even endorse violence or aggression
在某种程度上，这看起来非常直观，你觉得你经历了一些糟糕的事情，我提醒你经历过的糟糕事情，你内心的一部分会说我不希望那件糟糕的事情再次发生。这增加了我允许可能导致他人伤害的行为的意愿。是的，绝对是这样，我的意思是，我认为这双向影响，对吧？我的意思是，我认为提醒人们集体创伤，例如，可以使他们对局外人更加警惕，正如你所说，甚至更愿意支持针对局外人的暴力或侵略。
towards outsiders. But thinking of a common threat is also one way to bring people within a group closer together. I remember after 9-11 the way that Americans really felt like we were all one, because we were facing this really deep trauma together. And likewise, there is all sorts of evidence that when people feel that they have a common threat that they're facing, they band together. So, it's really interesting what you're really pointing out is that empathy in some ways has this double-edged sword quality to it, which is on the one hand it's prompting us to be outward looking, but it's also driven in some ways by factors about who's in our
但思考一个共同的威胁也是让群体内的人们更紧密联系在一起的一种方式。我记得9-11之后，美国人真的觉得我们是一体的，因为我们正在共同面对这种非常深刻的创伤。同样，有各种各样的证据表明，当人们感到他们面临共同威胁时，他们会团结起来。所以，你真正指出的是，同理心在某种程度上具有这种双刃剑的特质，一方面它促使我们向外看，但它在某种程度上也受到关于谁在我们的内群体中，谁不在我们的内群体中的因素的驱动。心理学家保罗·布鲁姆（Paul Bloom）写了《反同理心：理性同情的案例》（Against Empathy: The Case for Rational Compassion）一书，他认为同理心往往是狭隘的，而且往往是有偏见的，这就是为什么当我们要求人们有同理心时，我们实际上是在邀请他们产生偏见。这是真的吗？我认为保罗在某些方面是对的。绝对地，同理心往往是狭隘地开始的。我们本能的同理心可能更多地被部落内的人所驱动，而不是部落外的人。
in-group and who's not in our in-group. The psychologist Paul Bloom who wrote the book against empathy, the case for rational compassion, he argues that empathy tends to be parochial and it tends to be biased, and that's why when we ask people to be empathic, we're really inviting them to be prejudiced. Is that true? I think that Paul is right in certain ways. Absolutely, empathy sort of begins parochially. Our instinctive empathy might be more driven towards people in our tribe than outside of it.
我经常想到催产素，你知道，这种让我们与他人建立联系的化学物质，对吧？我们经常认为催产素是“爱情药物”或“拥抱荷尔蒙”，但事实证明，如果你给人们鼻内注射催产素，例如，他们会变得更关心群体内的人，但对群体外的人却不那么关心。本质上，在这种情况下，提高人们的同理心意味着提高他们的狭隘主义。我认为保罗和我分歧很大的一个地方是我们如何处理这些信息。
I often think of oxytocin, you know, this chemical that sort of causes us to bond to other people, right? We often think of oxytocin as the love drug or the cuddle hormone, but it turns out that if you give people oxytocin as the love drug or the cuddle hormone, but it turns out that if you give people oxytocin intranasally, for instance, they become more caring about people in their group, but less caring about people outside their group. In essence, sort of turning up people's empathy, in that case, means turning up their parochialism. I think a big place where Paul and I differ is on what we do with this information.
所以保罗，我认为，相信同理心往往是狭隘的，并且对内部人与外部人有偏见。所以我们应该完全放弃它。我的想法不同。我认为那是同理心运作方式的一个问题，但我试图让我们关注这样一个事实，即我们可以控制我们如何产生同理心，并对我们部署关怀的方式做出选择。如果我们认识到，嘿，我正在以一种狭隘和部落的方式产生同理心，我们可以尝试做出不同的选择并拓宽我们的同理心，
So Paul, I think, believes that empathy tends to be parochial and biased towards insiders versus outsiders. So we should give up on it altogether. I think differently. I think that's a problem with how empathy tends to operate, but I try to focus us on the fact that we can control how we empathize and make choices about the way that we deploy our caring. And if we recognize that, hey, I'm empathizing in a parochial way and a tribal way, we can try to make a different choice and broaden our empathy
甚至是对那些与我们不同的人。你和警察一起做了一些非常有趣的工作，你运用了你刚才谈到的这种洞察力。告诉我关于那项工作，并告诉我有时正确的建议实际上可能是告诉人们表现得少一点同理心。是的，为了这本书，我分析了华盛顿州的刑事司法培训中心。虽然这些警官对公民非常有同理心，但他们对其他警察更有同理心。
even towards people who are different for ourselves. You've done some very interesting work with police officers where you've brought to bear this insight that you just talked about. Tell me about that work and tell me about how sometimes the right recommendation might actually be to tell people behave a little less empathetically. Yeah, so for the book, I profiled Washington State's Criminal Justice Training Center. Although these officers were very empathic towards citizens, they were even more empathic
这包括那些可能涉及警察不当行为的警察，对吧？所以当我在那里时，发生了一起警察枪杀了一名手无寸铁的男子安东尼奥·赞布拉诺·蒙特斯（Antonio Zambrano Montez）的案件。在我访问CJTC期间，参与那次枪击事件的警官根本没有被起诉。所以这对华盛顿州的许多人来说似乎是一场司法闹剧，但CJTC的人坚持认为这些人是好人，只是犯了一个错误。那种对他们自己群体内的人的同理心，我觉得，这只是我的观点，可能干扰了他们理解世界其他地方如何看待所发生事情的能力。事实上，这与我的朋友埃米尔·布鲁诺（Emile Bruno）的研究是一致的。
towards fellow police officers. And that included fellow police officers who had engaged in potential police misconduct, right? So while I was there, there was a case of police officers who had shot an unarmed man named Antonio Zambrano Montez. And during my visit to CJTC, the officers involved in that shooting, they're not indicted at all. So that seemed like a travesty of justice
他研究了许多不同群体间背景下的狭隘同理心。他发现，有时如果你想预测一个人何时愿意对局外人采取侵略行为，或者不愿意与冲突另一方的人妥协，仅仅测量他们是否对外部的人有同理心是不够的。你还必须测量他们对自己群体有多大的同理心，事实证明，那些对群体内的人极其有同理心的人，即使他们也对局外人有同理心，也不愿意妥协，不愿意做任何可能威胁到他们自己部落的事情。
to many people in Washington state, but the people at CJTC were adamant that these were good guys who had just made a mistake. That level of empathy for people in their own group, I feel, and this is just my perspective, might have interfered with their ability to understand how the rest of the world saw what had happened. And in fact, this is consistent with research by my friend Emile Bruno.
所以这表明，有时如果我们想向其他文化开放，向政治分歧另一方的人开放。也许我们应该开始做的不仅仅是试图了解他们并对他们产生更多的同理心，而是要认识到我们是否对自己群体产生了太多的同理心，以至于我们在情感上无法灵活变通。
He's studied sort of parochial empathy in a lot of different intergroup contexts. And what he finds is that sometimes if you want to predict when someone will be willing to be aggressive towards outsiders, or unwilling to compromise with someone on the other side of a conflict, it's not enough to measure whether they empathize with the people on the outside. You have to also measure how empathic they are to their own group, and it turns out that people who are extraordinarily empathic towards people in their group, even if they're also empathic towards outsiders, are unwilling, even if they're also empathic towards outsiders, are unwilling to compromise, unwilling to do anything that could threaten their own
我想谈谈同理心的另一个悖论。你说大约50%的肿瘤学家在向患者传达坏消息时报告感到极度的悲伤。所以，即使同理心在医疗环境中是积极结果的非常强大的驱动力，例如，它似乎也伴随着一些个人代价。是的，事实上，即使让医学生模拟传达坏消息也会让他们感到焦虑，
tribe. So what this suggests is that sometimes if we want to open ourselves up to other cultures, to people on the other side of a political, or divide. Maybe what we should start out doing is not just trying to get to know them and empathize more with them, but to recognize if we're empathizing so much with our group that will be unable to be flexible emotionally.
让他们的手心开始出汗，心跳加速。同理心通常是有益的，包括在医疗环境中，对接受它的人来说。但是，对于给予它的人来说，它可能是一种职业危害。我了解到你的一个朋友是心理治疗师，她避免在一天结束时安排抑郁症患者，在某种程度上也是出于同样的原因。是的，是的，因为她觉得他们的负面情绪会渗入她，并使她无法与家人良好互动。我认为这是护理专业人员同理心双刃剑的一部分。一方面，这些人中的许多人是被一种对他人超自然的关怀所驱动去工作的。但另一方面，同样的关怀也会导致他们迷失自我，特别是如果他们处于非常紧张的医疗环境中，周围被他人的深重痛苦所包围。结果，我认为护理专业人员往往觉得他们陷入了在充分照顾他人与可能磨损自己或关闭自己之间的两难境地。
I wanna talk about another paradox of empathy. You say that about 50% of oncologists report feeling intense heartbreak when they communicate bad news to patients. So even as empathy is this very powerful driver of positive outcomes in medical settings, for example, it also seems to come at some personal cost. Yeah, in fact, even having medical students simulate delivering bad news makes them anxious,
这是医疗行业中所谓的“防御性非人化”。这种观点认为，医生和其他医疗保健专业人员觉得他们有时不得不关闭他们的同理心，停止将他们的病人视为人，只是为了让他们能继续做人。你引用了马克·彭泽（Mark Penzer）在20世纪70年代进行的一项有趣的研究，这是这种防御行为的另一个例子，人们避免那些他们可能被要求表现出同理心的情境。
makes their palms start to sweat and their heart start to race. Empathy is usually beneficial, including in medical contexts, for the people who receive it. But, it can be an occupational hazard for the people who give it. I understand that a friend of yours is a psychotherapist and she avoids scheduling depressed patients at the end of the day for in some ways the same reason. I understand that a friend of yours is a psychotherapist and she avoids scheduling depressed patients at the end of the day for in some ways the same reason. Yeah, yeah, because she feels as though their negative mood will seep into her and sort
使他们手心出汗，心跳加速。同理心通常是有益的，包括在医疗环境中，对接受它的人来说是这样。但对于提供它的人来说，这可能是一种职业危害。我听说你的一位朋友是心理治疗师，她避免在一天结束时安排抑郁症患者，在某种程度上也是出于同样的原因。我听说你的一位朋友是心理治疗师，她避免在一天结束时安排抑郁症患者，在某种程度上也是出于同样的原因。是的，是的，因为她觉得他们的负面情绪会渗透到她身上，并以某种方式
of leave her unable to interact well with her family. And I think this is part of the double-edged sword of empathy for people in caring professions. On the one hand, many of these people are driven to their work by a preternatural care for others. But on the other hand, that same care can cause them to lose themselves, especially if they're in really intense medical settings where they're surrounded by sort of chronically surrounded by other people's deep suffering. And as a result, oftentimes I think people in caring professions feel like they're stuck in a double bind between caring for other people adequately but potentially grinding themselves down or turning themselves off.
让她无法与家人进行良好的互动。我认为这是护理行业人员同理心双刃剑的一部分。一方面，这些人中的许多人是出于对他人超乎寻常的关怀而投身于这项工作。但另一方面，同样的关怀也可能导致他们迷失自我，尤其是在他们处于非常紧张的医疗环境中，周围长期充斥着他人的深重苦难时。因此，我认为护理行业的人员往往觉得他们陷入了一种两难境地：既要充分照顾他人，又可能因此耗尽自己或不得不关闭自己的情感。
This is something that is called in the medical profession, defensive dehumanization. The idea that physicians and other healthcare professionals feel like they sometimes have to turn off their empathy and stop seeing their patients as people just so they can go on being people. You cite this interesting study that Mark Penzer conducted in the 1970s, which is another example of this kind of defensive behavior, where people avoid situations where they might be called upon to demonstrate empathy.
这在医学界被称为防御性去人性化。这种观点认为，医生和其他医疗保健专业人员有时觉得他们必须关闭自己的同理心，不再把病人看作人，这样他们才能继续作为人生活下去。你引用了马克·彭泽在20世纪70年代进行的一项有趣的研究，这是这种防御性行为的另一个例子，人们会避免那些可能需要他们表现出同理心的情境。
What was the study and what did he find? Yeah, this was a fascinating study where Penser placed a table sort of asking for charitable donations in the middle of a busy sort of college student union. And the table had a request for donations to charity. And sometimes it had a picture of a sort of happy child on it. And other times it had a picture of a suffering child on it. Sometimes the table had no one manning it.
这项研究是什么？他发现了什么？是的，这是一项引人入胜的研究。潘瑟（Penser）在繁忙的大学生会中心中间摆了一张桌子，上面写着请求慈善捐款。桌子上放着请求捐款的牌子。有时上面有一张快乐孩子的照片，有时则是一张受苦孩子的照片。有时桌子旁没有人看管。
And sometimes the table had a person there who was in a wheelchair. And so the sad child and the person in the wheelchair were what Panser thought of as empathic triggers, things that when people saw them, they might feel sad. Maybe they'd feel obligated to donate as well. And what he found is that when he put those empathic triggers on the table, people actually walked further away.
有时桌子旁坐着一个坐轮椅的人。潘瑟认为悲伤的孩子和坐轮椅的人是“共情触发点”，当人们看到他们时，可能会感到悲伤。也许他们也会觉得有义务捐款。但他发现，当他把这些共情触发点放在桌子上时，人们反而走得更远了。
They sort of went out of their way to avoid the table more. It was almost as though they were trying to keep physical distance between them and something that would make them feel empathy, either because it would feel bad or because it would force them to do something like donate that maybe they didn't really want to do. I think a lot of us have this experience when we see, for instance, a homeless individual on the sidewalk ahead of us. I've heard of people who cross the street to avoid that encounter, maybe because they don't want to sort of see that person suffering close up because it will make them feel
他们甚至特意绕道避开这张桌子。就好像他们试图在自己和那些会让他们产生共情的事物之间保持物理距离，要么是因为这会让他们感觉不好，要么是因为这会迫使他们做一些他们并不真正想做的事情，比如捐款。我想我们很多人都有过这种经历，比如当我们看到前方人行道上有一个无家可归的人时。我听说有人会过马路来避开这种接触，也许是因为他们不想近距离看到那个人受苦，因为这会让他们感到
sad or guilty or both. There's some irony there, isn't there, which is that the person who is likely to actually be more empathic is also the person who's likely to cross the street because they recognize that the empathy that they have inside them is going to make them feel bad. Absolutely. Yeah, I've talked with lots of people who identify as empaths and basically say that they're crippled by their overabundance of care for other people, and that sometimes they avoid sort of busy cities overall, just because they don't want to be inundated with other people's pain. So what happens at the level of individuals,
悲伤或内疚，或者两者兼有。这其中有些讽刺，不是吗？那就是，那些实际上更有共情能力的人，往往也是最可能过马路的人，因为他们意识到内心产生的共情会让他们感觉不好。绝对是这样。是的，我和许多自认为是“共情者”的人交谈过，他们基本上说，他们因对他人的过度关心而感到痛苦，有时他们甚至完全避开繁忙的城市，只是因为不想被他人的痛苦所淹没。所以，发生在个人层面的事情，
also at some level manifests itself at the level of groups and even the level of nations. White Americans ask to read about the suffering of Native Americans, become more likely to say that Native Americans are unable to feel complex emotions, such as hope and shame. So in other words, empathy not only can produce pain, pain can not only produce disengagement, but we can actually almost dehumanize other people because we're so in some ways reluctant to accept the pain that comes with empathizing with them. Yeah, absolutely.
在某种程度上也体现在群体甚至国家层面。当美国白人被要求阅读关于美洲原住民苦难的内容时，他们更有可能认为美洲原住民无法感受复杂的感情，比如希望和羞耻。换句话说，共情不仅会产生痛苦，痛苦不仅会导致疏离，我们甚至可能在某种程度上将他人非人化，因为我们太不愿接受共情所带来的痛苦了。是的，绝对是这样。
Especially if you or a group that you belong to is responsible for that pain. Because then empathy can twist into a sense of guilt or even self-loathing. There are a lot of studies like this. In one classic set of studies from the 1950s, psychologists asked people to repeatedly shock, electrically, shock another person. And what they found was that when people had to shock someone else, they ended up saying that they liked that person less, almost as though they were defensively, again, turning down their empathy for that individual. again, turning down their empathy for that individual. And there's a dramatic example of this that was studied
特别是如果你或你所属的群体对那种痛苦负有责任时。因为那时，共情会扭曲成一种内疚感，甚至是自我厌恶。有很多这样的研究。在20世纪50年代的一系列经典研究中，心理学家要求人们反复电击另一个人。他们发现，当人们不得不电击别人时，他们最终会说自己不太喜欢那个人，就好像他们是在防御性地再次关闭对那个人的共情。再次关闭对那个人的共情。有一个戏剧性的例子，大约10年前对美国南部的死刑执行人员进行了研究。
about 10 years ago with death workers in the American South. These are executioners. And what they found is that people who worked on death rows were likely to dehumanize inmates and say that they had given up the right to be treated like people. And this was especially true if they were the ones physically involved in delivering lethal injections and the like. So again, in lots of ways, empathy can hurt us. It can be unpleasant or causes to view ourselves in ways that we don't like.
这些是行刑者。他们发现，在死囚牢房工作的人往往会将囚犯非人化，并说他们已经放弃了被当作人对待的权利。如果他们是亲手执行注射死刑等操作的人，情况尤其如此。所以，从很多方面来说，共情确实会伤害我们。它可能令人不快，或者导致我们以自己不喜欢的方式看待自己。
And that in turn can cause us to avoid it. don't like, and that in turn can cause us to avoid it. When we come back, how to manage the tricky balance, and how we can train ourselves with deliberate practice to be more empathetic. This message comes from NPR sponsor Smartwater. Smartwater is for the curious drinkers. The ones who are always looking for ways to make things a little bit better. That's why Smartwater created two new ways to hydrate. Smartwater alkaline with 9 plus pH and Smartwater antioxidant with added selenium. And now you can order Smart water by saying Alexa order smart water. Smart water. That's pretty smart.
而这反过来又会导致我们回避它。不喜欢，而这反过来又会导致我们回避它。回来后，我们将讨论如何处理这种微妙的平衡，以及我们如何通过刻意练习来训练自己变得更有共情能力。本节目由NPR赞助商Smartwater提供。Smartwater专为好奇的饮水者准备。那些总是寻找方法让事情变得更好一点的人。这就是为什么Smartwater创造了两种新的补水方式。Smartwater碱性水，pH值9以上；以及添加了硒的Smartwater抗氧化水。现在你可以通过说“Alexa，订购Smartwater”来订购Smartwater。Smartwater。这很聪明。
This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. During his month-long performance art piece, tens of thousands of paintballs were fired at Wafa Bilal in The white walls of his gallery turned fluorescent yellow. As you can just keep repeating, getting hit. On day 11, a shootoff from Estonia began bombarding his lamp until it fell apart. It was sad for me because the lamp represent just the only thing that stayed alive beside me in this space, especially at night. Viewers online could see Wafa's sadness. Later that day, one of those viewers came to visit him in person. The lamp was totally broken and I have a person here walked in with a brand new lamp.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》（Hidden Brain），我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。在他为期一个月的行为艺术表演中，数万颗彩球射向瓦法·比拉尔（Wafa Bilal），他画廊的白墙变成了荧光黄色。你可以一直重复，被击中。第11天，一个来自爱沙尼亚的射击者开始轰炸他的灯，直到它散架。这让我很难过，因为那盏灯代表了在这个空间里除了我之外唯一活着的东西，尤其是在晚上。在线观众可以看到瓦法的悲伤。那天晚些时候，其中一位观众亲自来看他。灯完全坏了，有一个人走进来，带着一盏全新的灯。
Hi, my name is Matt, I was watching the camera this morning. I saw the lamp went out. So I had some time, I thought I'd run the target. I got a new lamp and some light bulb. So I know sometimes you need all the help you can get even in a situation like this. So I bring that by and I just help you out a little bit. Jimmy will talk about this moment. Perfect strangers are attacking Waffa,
嗨，我叫马特，我今天早上一直在看摄像头。我看到灯灭了。所以我有点时间，我想我应该跑一趟。我买了一盏新灯和一些灯泡。我知道有时即使在这种情况下，你也需要你能得到的所有帮助。所以我把它带过来，只是想帮你一点忙。吉米将谈论这一刻。完全的陌生人在攻击瓦法，
and then a perfect stranger shows up to help him. What do you think causes someone to take the step of saying, this problem is my problem, this suffering is my suffering? Well, it's a beautiful story, and you know, there's so many like it, and I think it really, Waffafa's story shows you the two sides of how empathy can work in our modern context, right? On the one hand, you've got people who are anonymous,
然后一个完全的陌生人出现来帮助他。你认为是什么促使一个人采取行动说：“这个问题是我的问题，这种痛苦是我的痛苦”？嗯，这是一个美丽的故事，你知道，有很多类似的故事，我认为瓦法的故事确实向你展示了共情在我们现代背景下如何运作的两个方面，对吧？一方面，你有一些匿名的人，
sort of feeling as though they've had the breaklines cut from their social lives, and they can do whatever they want without having to worry about the consequences. So they're acting aggressively towards a total stranger. On the other hand, you have someone who taps into that stranger's story, who's paying attention to Waffa, he's watching the video of him, and realizing what he's going through, sort of able to tap into the story of this stranger, and that instead of destroying his empathy, builds it, stretches it towards this person
感觉好像他们的社交生活刹车线被切断了，他们可以做任何他们想做的事，而不必担心后果。所以他们对一个完全的陌生人表现出攻击性。另一方面，有一个人与那个陌生人的故事产生了共鸣，他一直在关注瓦法，看着他的视频，意识到他正在经历什么，能够与这个陌生人的故事产生共鸣，这不仅没有摧毁他的共情，反而建立了它，并将其延伸到这个人身上，
and drives him, inspires him to help him. I forgot to mention something is really important. Matt is a Marine. Matt wasn't the only visitor. Hi, I'm Laura. I live here in Chicago, so I came down to the gallery and I made some of my famous muffins. It's actually my sister's recipe. I know this the other night when you went to sleep, they had one black sarkan and white
并驱使他、激励他去帮助他。我忘了提一件非常重要的事情。马特是一名海军陆战队员。马特不是唯一的访客。嗨，我是劳拉。我住在芝加哥，所以我来到画廊，做了我著名的松饼。这其实是我姐姐的食谱。我前几天晚上注意到当你睡觉时，他们有一只黑袜子和一只白袜子。
sark. So I brought you some socks. There were lots of people online who helped Waffa too. Sometimes they took control of the painball gun by repeatedly pressing down a key and pointing the gun away from I had about 36 or so people pressing the button down on the left, presenting people from panning into my direction. Here is Waffa on day 31, after stepping outside the gallery building for the first time in a month. And the whole idea is reinforced my belief in humanity and human kindness. So thank you very much for keeping the hope alive. And please keep the conversation going.
袜子。所以我给你带了一些袜子。网上也有很多人帮助瓦法。有时他们通过反复按下一个键并将枪指向远离我的方向来控制彩球枪。大约有36个人按下了左边的按钮，阻止人们向我的方向扫射。这是第31天的瓦法，在一个月内第一次走出画廊大楼后。整个想法加强了我对人类和人类善良的信念。所以非常感谢你们让希望保持活力。请继续保持对话。
It may seem surprising that Wafa's month in the paintball gallery left him feeling optimistic about humanity, but he's not alone in that optimism. Jamil Zaki also thinks there are ways we might use technology to form connections with people whom we previously did not see as being like ourselves. He's done work looking at how virtual reality might help people identify with others, whose lives are very different from their own. What we wanted to do is use technology to bring people not just to sort of observe the experiences of a homeless individual, but observe them from the inside. So we had a simulation where people
瓦法在彩球画廊度过的一个月让他对人类感到乐观，这似乎令人惊讶，但他并不孤单。贾米尔·扎基（Jamil Zaki）也认为，我们可以利用技术与那些我们以前认为与自己不同的人建立联系。他做了一些研究，观察虚拟现实如何帮助人们认同那些生活与自己截然不同的人。我们想做的是利用技术，不仅让人们观察无家可归者的经历，而且从内部观察他们。所以我们做了一个模拟，人们
went through a series of scenes. These are sort of virtual reality scenes of what it might be like to become homeless. So in one scene, they've been evicted from their apartment and they're trying to figure out what they can sell to make ends meet and stay in their apartment just one more month. In the second scene, they've failed to stay in their apartment and are now sort of sleeping in their car, which is then impounded. And then in a third scene, they're on a local bus line, which in fact in the Bay Area, there is a bus line that homeless individuals often take to for shelter during the night. So again, this showed people in an interactive, immersive way, the process that an individual might
经历了一系列场景。这些是关于成为无家可归者可能是什么样子的虚拟现实场景。在一个场景中，他们被房东赶出了公寓，他们正在想办法卖掉什么东西来维持生计，并在公寓里再住一个月。在第二个场景中，他们没能留在公寓里，现在睡在车里，车随后被扣押了。在第三个场景中，他们在当地的一条公交线上，事实上在湾区，确实有一条无家可归者经常在晚上乘坐去避难的公交线。所以，这再次以一种互动、沉浸式的方式向人们展示了一个人成为无家可归者时可能经历的过程。
go through when they become homeless. What we found was that this short simulation powerfully affected people's empathy for the homeless. Even a month later, people who had gone through that simulation, as opposed to a control condition, were less likely to dehumanize homeless individuals. And they were more supportive of policies that would produce affordable housing for people in the Bay Area, which is a very sort of hot button issue around here. So again, this suggests that by putting ourselves
我们发现，这种简短的模拟有力地影响了人们对无家可归者的共情。即使一个月后，经历过该模拟的人，与对照组相比，也不太可能将无家可归者非人化。他们更支持那些能为湾区人民提供经济适用房的政策，这在当地是一个非常热门的话题。所以，这再次表明，通过将我们自己
into the story of people who on the surface appeared different from us, we can recognize as you put it nicely, our common humanity with them, and that can trigger empathy in a really natural way. There are also some less high tech ways to get people to walk in the shoes of other people. And one of the things you mentioned in the book is the idea of the theater. How does being an actor in some ways prompt you to develop the muscle of empathy? Yeah, I mean, if you think about what acting is, that you really immerse yourself so deeply in the character, that you stop being yourself and start being them for a little while.
置于那些表面上看起来与我们不同的人的故事中，我们可以像你所说的那样，认识到我们与他们共同的人性，这可以以一种非常自然的方式触发共情。还有一些不太高科技的方法可以让人们设身处地为他人着想。你在书中提到的其中一件事是戏剧的概念。作为一名演员，在某种程度上如何促使你发展共情肌肉？是的，我的意思是，如果你想想什么是表演，你真的会如此深入地沉浸在角色中，以至于你停止做你自己，开始做他们一段时间。
I mean, I'd say it's more than walking a mile in their shoes. You're almost walking a mile in their skin. And as a result there's some evidence at least that acting in fact bolsters people's empathy. So in a great set of studies, Taliah Goldstein looked at adolescents who were in performing arts high schools and compared them, you know at the beginning and end of the year, to students who are being trained in visual arts. And what she found is that sort of acting, training and acting, improved kids' empathy more than training in a different type of art, which is not to say that training in the
我的意思是，我认为这不仅仅是设身处地为他们着想。你几乎是在他们的皮肤里走了一英里。因此，至少有一些证据表明，表演实际上增强了人们的共情能力。在一系列伟大的研究中，塔利亚·戈尔茨坦（Taliah Goldstein）观察了表演艺术高中的青少年，并将他们（在学年开始和结束时）与接受视觉艺术培训的学生进行了比较。她发现，表演训练比其他类型的艺术训练更能提高孩子的共情能力，这并不是说视觉艺术培训没有优势，我相信它有，但以演员那样的方式体现另一个人。
visual arts doesn't have advantages, I'm sure it does, but sort of embodying another person in the way that actors do. Almost just like, I would say, a performance-enhancing drug for empathy, if you will. In some ways, does the same go for narrative fiction? I mean, I feel like when I'm reading a great novel, you know, I, as you say it a second ago, become transported. I become, you know, a woman who's living in the 19th century. And in some ways, deeply written, beautifully written narrative fiction has this ability to
几乎就像，我会说，一种共情的“兴奋剂”，如果你愿意的话。在某种程度上，叙事小说也是如此吗？我的意思是，我觉得当我读一本伟大的小说时，你知道，我，正如你刚才所说，被传送了。我成为了，你知道，一个生活在19世纪的女人。在某种程度上，深刻、优美的叙事小说有这种能力，
pull us deep into the lives of other people. Absolutely, yeah, I mean, this is why I love fiction as well, because it really allows us to effortlessly voyage into the lives of other people and not just see them again from the outside, but see them from the inside. There's a fair amount of evidence now that sort of the more fiction that people read, the more empathic that they become. So there's a number of correlational studies that show, for instance, that children who read lots of story books versus those who read less fiction become more empathic. And that's holds for adults also.
把我们深深地拉入他人的生活中。绝对是这样，是的，我的意思是，这也是我喜欢小说的地方，因为它确实让我们能够毫不费力地航行到他人的生活中，不仅再次从外部看到他们，而且从内部看到他们。现在有相当多的证据表明，人们阅读的小说越多，他们就变得越有共情能力。因此，有许多相关研究表明，例如，阅读大量故事书的孩子与阅读较少小说的孩子相比，变得更有共情能力。这对成年人也适用。
Unfortunately for me, reading nonfiction-like scientific articles, not that helpful. Journal of personality and social psychology doesn't do it? It's not really the empathy gym that some of us are looking for, but there's also some experimental evidence now coming out that even small doses of fiction produce small but reliable improvements in people's empathy. And I think this is especially important because fiction is one of the most powerful ways
不幸的是，对我来说，阅读非小说类科学文章，并没有那么有帮助。《人格与社会心理学杂志》没用吗？它并不是我们有些人正在寻找的共情健身房，但现在也有一些实验证据表明，即使是少量的阅读小说也能在人们的共情能力上产生小而可靠的改善。我认为这尤其重要，因为小说是最强大的方式之一，
to connect with people who are different from us, who maybe we might not have a chance to meet otherwise, right? So for instance, you can maybe it would be hard to meet someone who is, I don't know, a Bolivian minor, but you could probably go to a bookstore and find a novel about their experiences. And likewise, there's some evidence, for instance, that when people read novelistic, vivid accounts of the experiences of Arab Americans
与那些与我们不同的人建立联系，那些我们可能没有机会见到的人，对吧？所以，例如，你可能很难见到一个，我不知道，玻利维亚矿工，但你可能可以去书店找到一本关于他们经历的小说。同样，有一些证据表明，例如，当人们阅读关于阿拉伯裔美国人经历的小说式、生动的叙述时，
or people of different gender identities than themselves, they form greater empathy for those other groups. We've talked in different ways about how redefining who's in the in-group can reshape our capacity for empathy. You mentioned a very interesting research study in the book involving fans of the Manchester United soccer team. Do you remember that study? And if you do, can you tell me about it? Yeah, I love this study from Mark Levine and his colleague. So they recruited rabid Manchester United fans. And you know, fandom in UK soccer is very important and they asked them to write about why they loved Manchester United so much and then told them that they would go to a different building on campus to watch film of Man You Playing.
或者与他们性别认同不同的人，他们会对这些群体产生更大的共情。我们以不同的方式讨论了重新定义谁是“内群体”成员如何重塑我们的共情能力。你在书中提到了一个非常有趣的研究，涉及曼联足球队的球迷。你还记得那个研究吗？如果记得，你能告诉我吗？是的，我喜欢马克·莱文（Mark Levine）和他的同事做的这项研究。所以他们招募了狂热的曼联球迷。你知道，英国足球的粉丝文化非常重要，他们让他们写下为什么他们如此热爱曼联，然后告诉他们，他们将去校园里的另一栋楼看曼联比赛的电影。
While they were on their way across campus, they came across a jogger who appeared to twist his ankle and fall to the ground, writhing in pain. This person was in fact an actor, and the trick here was that the psychologists made it such that sometimes that actor was wearing a Manchester United jersey. Sometimes they were wearing a jersey of Liverpool, which at the time was Manchester United's most hated rival, and other times they were wearing a blank jersey. And what they found was that man-u-fans were more than willing to help fellow man-u-fans, but also more than willing to basically step over
当他们在校园里走的时候，他们遇到了一个慢跑者，他似乎扭伤了脚踝，倒在地上，痛苦地扭动。这个人实际上是一个演员，这里的诀窍是心理学家让那个演员有时穿着曼联的球衣。有时他们穿着利物浦的球衣，利物浦在当时是曼联最痛恨的对手，还有其他时候他们穿着一件空白的球衣。他们发现，曼联球迷非常愿意帮助曼联球迷，但也非常愿意基本上跨过
a Liverpool fan as they sort of rived on the ground in pain. This is sort of classic tribalism in terms of our empathy and generosity, but what I love about this study is that the psychologist ran a second version of it. And here, instead of asking man, you fans to write about why they loved the team, they asked them to write about why they loved soccer, why it is such a beautiful game. And then they put them in the same scenario.
一个利物浦球迷，因为他们痛苦地在地上扭动。这是我们共情和慷慨方面的经典部落主义，但我喜欢这项研究的地方在于，心理学家进行了第二个版本。在这里，他们没有要求曼联球迷写下为什么他们热爱这支球队，而是要求他们写下为什么他们热爱足球，为什么它是一项如此美丽的运动。然后他们把他们放在同样的场景中。
What they found was that after writing about how much they loved soccer, individuals were not just willing to help fellow man U-Fans, but also willing to help Liverpool fans. They still didn't help the person in the blank jersey, which I guess suggested it's better to be part of any tribe than part of none. But I think there's a deeper takeaway from this study, which is that yes, it's easier to empathize with people who are like us than unlike us. But all of us have many different selves inside us at any given moment. And each self carries with it a different group, maybe of a different size.
他们发现，在写下他们有多热爱足球后，个人不仅愿意帮助曼联球迷，也愿意帮助利物浦球迷。他们仍然没有帮助穿空白球衣的人，我想这表明成为任何部落的一部分都比不属于任何部落要好。但我认为这项研究有一个更深层的启示，那就是，是的，与像我们的人相比，与不像我们的人产生共情更容易。但我们每个人在任何特定时刻内心都有许多不同的自我。每个自我都携带一个不同的群体，也许规模不同。
So if I think of myself, for instance, as a Stanford person, well then people at UC Berkeley are my mortal enemies, especially during the big game. But if I think of myself as a Californian, then my in-group, the people who deserve my empathy and who it's easy to empathize with, that group grows. And if I can think of myself as, I don't know, an American or a human being, then that group will. And if I can think of myself as I don't know an American or a
所以如果我把自己想成，例如，一个斯坦福人，那么加州大学伯克利分校的人就是我的死敌，特别是在大比赛期间。但如果我把自己想成一个加州人，那么我的内群体，那些值得我共情且容易产生共情的人，那个群体就会扩大。如果我能把自己想成，我不知道，一个美国人或一个人，那么那个群体就会。如果我能把自己想成我不知道一个美国人或一个
human being, then that group will grow even further. You know, I'm thinking about the story you told me about your parents' divorce when you were a small child. You write in the book about your parents that two people's experiences could differ so drastically, yet both be true and deep, is maybe the most important lesson I've ever learned. I think, you know, I often attribute that period of my life to really making me who I am at the deepest level. I mean, I think not for nothing, they say that research is
人，那么那个群体就会进一步扩大。你知道，我在想你告诉我的关于你父母在你小时候离婚的故事。你在书中写到关于你父母的事，两个人的经历可能如此截然不同，但都是真实而深刻的，这可能是我学到的最重要的教训。我想，你知道，我经常把那段生活归功于真正塑造了最深层面的我。我的意思是，我认为他们说研究是
research, right, at least in psychology, people tend to gravitate towards ideas that have made an impact on their life. And I think for me, empathizing with my parents was a survival skill that I needed just to sort of keep my family together at some level. But it also taught me at a much broader level that people can be fundamentally different from each other for fundamentally similar reasons. My parents had totally different values, not because one of them was wrong or because one of them was a bad person, but because of the lives that they had lived and the experiences
研究，对吧，至少在心理学中，人们倾向于被那些对他们的生活产生影响的想法所吸引。我想对我来说，与我父母产生共情是一种生存技能，我需要它来在某种程度上保持我的家庭在一起。但它也在更广泛的层面上教会我，人们可能因为根本上相似的原因而从根本上不同。我父母有完全不同的价值观，不是因为他们其中一个是错的，或者因为他们其中一个是坏人，而是因为他们所过的生活和经历，
that they had had and the things that had hurt them and helped them along the way. I think that this is a lesson that I try to impart to all of my students as well, is that, you know, oftentimes when we encounter someone who's different for ourselves and has an opinion or viewpoint, maybe that we even abhor, it's easy to just view them as being either obtuse or dishonest, or both. But that's a mistake. It's something that just view them as being either obtuse or dishonest or both.
以及他们在这一路上伤害过他们和帮助过他们的事情。我认为这是我试图传授给我所有学生的教训，那就是，你知道，通常当我们遇到一个与我们不同且有观点或看法的人时，也许我们甚至厌恶，很容易就把他们看作是愚钝或不诚实，或者两者兼有。但那是一个错误。这只是把他们看作是愚钝或不诚实，或者两者兼有。
But that's a mistake. It's something that psychologists call naive realism, the idea that your version of the world is the world. And I think that empathy at a deep level is the understanding that someone else's world is just as real as yours. Jamil Zaki is the author of the War for Kindness, building empathy in a fractured world. He conducts research on empathy at Stanford University. Jamil, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain.
但那是一个错误。这是心理学家所说的“朴素现实主义”，即认为你的世界版本就是世界本身。我认为深层次的共情是理解他人的世界和你的一样真实。贾米尔·扎基是《善良的战争：在破碎的世界中建立共情》（The War for Kindness, building empathy in a fractured world）的作者。他在斯坦福大学进行共情研究。贾米尔，感谢你今天加入《隐藏的大脑》。
Thanks for having me. This week's show was produced by Path Shah, and edited by Tara Boyle and Jenny Schmidt. Our team includes Raina Cohen, Laura Correll and Thomas Loom. Our unsung hero today is Rosa Portillo. She's a part of NPR's janitorial staff. Every day Rosa travels the floors of our building, keeping our kitchens and bathrooms clean. She also offers impromptu Spanish lessons to everyone who asks for them.
谢谢你的邀请。本周的节目由帕斯·沙（Path Shah）制作，塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）和珍妮·施密特（Jenny Schmidt）编辑。我们的团队包括雷娜·科恩（Raina Cohen）、劳拉·科雷尔（Laura Correll）和托马斯·卢姆（Thomas Loom）。我们今天的无名英雄是罗莎·波蒂略（Rosa Portillo）。她是NPR清洁人员的一员。罗莎每天穿梭在我们大楼的楼层，保持我们的厨房和浴室清洁。她还为每一个向她请教的人提供即兴的西班牙语课程。
Thank you, Rosa. For more Hidden Brain, you can find us on Facebook and Twitter. If you like this episode, please share it with someone you know. When a big obstacle pops up in your life, it can be hard to focus on other priorities. We're hungry and then this thing starts going off in the head saying, do you realize we're hungry? Have I mentioned we're hungry?
谢谢你，罗莎。更多《隐藏的大脑》内容，你可以在Facebook和Twitter上找到我们。如果你喜欢这一集，请分享给你认识的人。当生活中出现一个大障碍时，很难专注于其他优先事项。我们饿了，然后脑子里就开始响起来说，你意识到我们饿了吗？我提到我们饿了吗？
We're hungry. Next week, we'll continue our U2.0 series with an episode about making mindful, short and long-term choices. I'm Shankar Vedantim and this is NPR. Going on a big group trip always sounds good in theory, but it can get tricky when you get there and have totally different expectations. Check out NPR LifeKits' new guide on Navigating Group Travel or subscribe to LifeKits All Guides for all our episodes all in one place. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们饿了。下周，我们将继续我们的U2.0系列，讨论关于做出正念的、短期和长期的选择。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这是NPR。进行一次大型团体旅行在理论上听起来总是很好，但当你到达那里并且有完全不同的期望时，它可能会变得棘手。查看NPR LifeKit关于导航团体旅行的新指南，或订阅LifeKit的所有指南，将我们所有的剧集集中在一个地方。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。